how exactly does oda do all that surely
it must all be planned out down to the
very last detail
or is oda simply a freestyling genius
who prefers to improvise everything with
miraculous consistency to answer this
question i wanted no i
need it to find out more about oda as a
person
and as a storyteller which is
surprisingly hard because as you guys
might know the man likes to stay on the
sidelines preferring to let us work
speak for itself there wasn't a lot of
articles magazines or even interviews of
oda to go with
but i had to start somewhere as i poured
through the little material that i had
the first thing i came to realize is
that oda or oda sensei as most people in
japan like to call him respectfully
is actually a little bit dishonest when
it comes to talking about his work for
instance in one interview oda stated
that he doesn't really try to put any
deeper meanings into a story however
this is clearly not the case as we all
know that one piece is notorious for its
underlying themes and political and
moral problems in its narrative
the racism towards the fishman the
injustice of the world government
the power of dreams
freedom
you get what i mean now in another
interview oda stated that he absolutely
hates tearjerkers and storytelling
however oda himself admits that one
piece doesn't exactly suffer from a
shortage of heartbreaking moments and in
general oda likes to mention that he
simply draws what he feels like drawing
and often just improvises as he moves
along
a famous example of this is for example
the introduction of the supernova as i
found out through my digging however
this is also not entirely true because
as many of those working with him have
commented oda is an absolute
perfectionist when it comes to his work
and oda himself knows and acknowledges
this his obsession with telling a
perfect story actually comes up quite
frequently in his interviews here when
asked what about his work makes him the
most happy his answer was
that probably have to be whenever i make
a good story i'm a total wreck when i
can't do my job well i wind up mopping
if i don't feel like i've fully
completed a good story i can't rest
until i make up for it the next week in
writing one piece oda gets his
inspiration from history folklore and
especially from film
his favorite directors include the likes
of tim burton hayao miyazaki and quentin
tarantino
and what all of these directors have in
common is their desire to tell the
perfect story
so
improvisation
and perfectionism can these two things
actually go together i wondered and even
if oda somehow did figure out that a
long-running story can keep delivering
the question again is
how
i had to dig deeper first off i've
always kind of wondered how oda had the
time and of course also the energy to
come up with random fun facts about one
piece characters and share them in an
spss or on some other platform looking
through more of the interviews i
stumbled across one mind-blowing
technique that oda uses not only to keep
the story full of energy and interesting
but surely must be the foundation for
his crazy web of characters
all characters in one piece are designed
to be real people
let me explain when writing his story
oda seems to put himself into the shoes
of each of his characters as you might
for example do when trying to understand
another person's perspective in the real
world
in this way he's able to discern what a
character would realistically do in any
given moment
basically next level empathy so
how does he do that well have you ever
wondered what these really weird details
are that we often learn about characters
in manga
like what is doflamingo's favorite food
what is zorro's blood type or
how tall is law oh and by the way
when is kaido's birthday as hirohiko
araki the author of jojo explains in his
book
it's apparently considered best practice
among manga cars to create crazily
detailed profiles of each major
character
everything from basic physical
attributes over their past histories
down to specific personality traits and
quirks now this may seem like an
unnecessary amount of time to spend
thinking about each individual character
especially since many of these facts
don't even come up in the story in the
first place
but that's precisely the point getting
to know your characters so well and in
so much detail that you can practically
predict what they would do next
this is
how oda writes
that's why one piece characters rally
or dare i even say never feel out of
character but oda takes this even
further i write in pretty menu detail
when someone makes a certain action
how people around that individual will
respond normally when making a story
move along it's fine to simply draw the
main characters but rather than that i
want to write about what the townspeople
are thinking by putting all feelings in
their place within a scene
this is what we're dealing with here
folks oda basically lets his characters
perform like actors on a stage and
ultimately it's this method of organic
writing that leads to the story
inevitably sidetracking and expanding on
its own
having created his characters in such
rich detail they pretty much advance the
plot for oda
this is next level writing there is one
big problem with this kind of writing
technique though
it's very
very easy to lose focus and have the
story move further and further away from
the original plot i'm sure you've seen
stories like this before where suddenly
the sight plot becomes the main plot and
readers are left totally confused as to
what actually happened to the original
story however oda seems to do this so
flawlessly
that every single plot actually seems to
contribute to the oval story arc he
himself said that the only things that
he was absolutely sure of before even
starting one piece were luffy his powers
the ending and that he wanted to draw
one heck of an epic adventure pretty
much the exact opposite of having
everything and everyone planned out
right from the start
however these specific elements are
actually just what any good story needs
before you start writing they basically
act as a sort of framework with a set of
rules to operate in
oda knew who luffy is and exactly what
he wanted right from the start
he also knew what the story would be
about and what would mark its beginning
and ending this way no matter how his
characters would behave or move
throughout the story
they would always be striving toward
that ending giving the story structure
and direction despite this improvised
style
and even further than that establishing
the rules of the world right from the
start allows for consistent and organic
plots there are devil fruits with
special powers in this world it's a
world of pirates mostly covered by water
monsters exist and anything can happen
on the grand line
oda establishes these things right from
the start and within these rules can let
his characters run completely free this
exceptionally strong set of rules and
the overall direction of the plot that
oda has established ultimately allow him
to let his characters move freely and
the plot take him wherever it leads him
and so it finally clicked for me
the secret to oda's genius is that he's
able to flawlessly combine planning and
improvisation to create an entire new
world of thousands of individual
characters and hundreds of locations all
based on his inspiration
and imagination a story that rightfully
has breached 1 000 chapters and that
boasts having set the world record for
most copies published for the same comic
book by the same author it clearly is
the best selling mod in history for a
reason now if you were just as impressed
by this as i am
let me tell you that you can copy this
approach as well to reach your own goals
in the future